to go back to your point about mansion  claiming he doesn't like attention i  mean it's like the guy's writing op-eds  in newspapers regularly to you know a  handful of notable times in this early  presidency of joe biden talking about  why he's not for this and why this and  that and why we need to compromise for a  guy who doesn't like attention he's  taking a lot of meetings and writing a  lot of op-eds that no one's forcing him  to write yep and he goes on cable news  all the time you could probably argue he  has more power than chuck schumer right  i mean like in some way think about the  most powerful people in washington  obviously biden's going to be at the top  of the list you can come up with some  other people as well but mansion's right  up there with them no doubt about it